هذه النصائح ستنفعكم كثيرا خلال السفر فمن
الشائع ارتكاب بعض الاخطاء عند السفر خاصه
مع الوجهات التي نزورها للمره الاولى لكن
بعض الاخطاء قد تجعل التجربه بالكامل
مخيبه للامال ومضيعه للمال فنستعرض اكثر
اخطاء السفر شيوعا اولها وضع برنامج سفر
طموح جدا كان تخطط مثلا للذهاب الى باريس
صباحا واستكشاف مارسيليا مساء تذكر انك لن
تستطيع زياره بلد كامل في سفره واحده حتى
لا تشعر بالاحباط كذلك نفاد الاموال في
السفر قد يكون ازمه كبرى ضع ميزانيه
واقعيه والتزم بها واترك مساحه للنفقات
غير المتوقعه والطوارئ من الاخطاء ايضا
حجز الرحلات مع ترانزيت قصير وتفويت رحله
المتابعه الى الوجهه النهائيه ننصح بدلا
من ذلك بمنح نفسك ساعتين على الاقل بين
الرحلات استعدادا لاي سيناريو تاخير محتمل
واحذر اغراء ان الشالين باشياء ثمينه ننصح
هنا بالا تبدو سائحا جدا في مظهرك في
اوروبا مثلا يستهدف اللصوص الساعه الفاخره
فمن المفضل الا ترطي الا ترتدي واحده في
الاماكن السياحيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات